there have been several explosions near
a military air base in
russian-controlled crimea local
authorities say one person was killed
and five injured in the blast
well for more on
for more on this let's bring in john
hendren who is in the ukrainian capital
of kiev john what more do we know about
these explosions in crimea
well it's something of a mystery um
ukraine says it is not responsible for
those explosions russia says that they
were an accident that munitions exploded
but it was a series of explosions by one
report more than a dozen explosions so
one munition dump would have had to set
off many more if that were the case
ukrainian authorities suggest it might
have been the work of saboteurs and
that's interesting because
crimea was annexed by russia in 2014
it's been many years there has not been
fighting there recently because it is so
firmly in russian control so it would be
something of an unusual event if ukraine
were to have shelled it
by all accounts those explosions
happened without any kind of
sound of a missile strike that occurred
beforehand or anything so
it would either be what the russians say
it is an explosion at a munition site or
the act of saboteurs as the ukrainians
say but in any case it's something of a
mystery in an area where there is not
really ongoing fighting in a solidly
controlled uh russian uh controlled area
we also have some news on the zaparia
nuclear plant which is in an area of
active fighting uh in in the southern
part of ukraine uh i talked to
petrocotin he's the head of energo atom
the company that controls that nuclear
plant he says they no longer really have
control of it because it's under russian
authority but the ukrainian workers are
still there and he says there are four
lines that connect that to the ukrainian
electrical grid and he says the russians
have severed three of those four lines
he said it is their intention
in his opinion to cut the fourth line
and then connect it to the russian
nuclear system
in crimea he says if that happens it
will have to run on diesel generators
and if those diesel generators run out
there is the possibility of a meltdown
along the lines of chernobyl he says
that is an emergent situation and he
wants the international atomic energy
agency to go in there and he wants it to
be a demilitarized zone so that that
plant can be operated safely operated
safely outside of the fire that has been
going on there well thank you very much
for that update that's john hendren in
kiev for us